- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the
latest programs.
- [Male] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained, long the
master of fire, tools and language but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- [Veerabhadran] We heard from Jeff
Severinghaus about the greenhouse effect
of carbon dioxide and Venus. And that
brought me fond memories, when 45 years
ago I got started in this field by taking
the quantum mechanics of the carbon
dioxide molecule and tried to figure out
how it maintains the climate of Venus and
Mars. So how did I go from quantum
mechanics to talk about the topic which is
totally foreign to me in pursuit of the
common good. So I have to walk you through
how my science led me into the villages of
India and Kenya and finally found myself
face to face with Pope Francis last year.
And that's what gave me this idea of the
pursuit of the common good. So let me
start with a 30 second lesson on climate
and climate change. The fundamental energy
source for the planet is sunlight,
considered solar energy. Not all of
that is absorbed by the planet. The
intervening clouds, and ice sheets and
surface bounces some of these back.
Somewhat 70% is absorbed by the planet.
That heats the planet and it gives off
this energy in the infrared wavelengths.
We call it heat radiation, infrared
radiation. But not all of that can escape
to space. The intervening atmosphere,
particularly water vapor and carbon
dioxide acts like a blanket and traps this
heat. In fact, the blanket is a good
analog if not a metaphor. The blanket
keeps you warm on a cold winter night not
because it gives off any heat. It traps
your body heat. That's exactly how this
gases trap the planet's infrared heat.
Which is what we call the greenhouse
effect. Nature gave us a thick blanket,
literally, how thick the blanket wall is.
So without that the planet would be so
frozen beyond anything we have seen in the
ice ages which Jeff showed us. So now,
what we've been doing is adding to that
blanket making the blanket thicker. So the
first of this we have about it, carbon
dioxide. And that was worked out more than
100 years ago by Svante Arrhenius the
famous chemist. He did some of the most
definitive calculations in 1896. I know
this paper very well because the Swedish
Academy at the 100th anniversary invited
me to write a detailed critique of this.
So for nearly 80 years after the
publication of this paper, we thought
carbon dioxide was the only molecule
causing the greenhouse effect. In fact,
many talks today focus on the CO2. After I
finished graduate school, I stumbled on
this totally shocking and surprising
discovery given for myself that we were
releasing other compounds. Particularly
the chlorofluorocarbons, CFCs. And my work
showed, taking again the study from the
quantum mechanics of the CFC molecule,
addition of one molecule of CFC has the
same greenhouse effect as adding 10,000 to
15,000 molecules of carbon dioxide. This
is mind you purely synthetic gas used as
refrigerants and propellants. But the CFCs
are also involved in damaging the ozone
layer. So the Montreal Protocol in 1980s
phased out, banned the use of chemicals
after the discovery of the Antarctic ozone
hole. Just in the last five years, my work
was recognized and the Economist called
the Montreal Protocol as the best climate
mitigation strategy. Because my work had
shown if we had not banned CFCs, the CFC
alone would have caused a half a degree
warming so far. Okay. So now let me go to
the real gorilla on the table which is
carbon dioxide. You know the theory is
being attacked. So the key thing is to
remember any theory is judged by its
predictions. So in 1980, I teamed up with
the famous meteorologist Roland Madden. We
took the observed climate fluctuations so
called noise and said when will we detect
the signal: carbon dioxide warming. So we
predicted if Arrhenius' theory was right,
we should see the warming by year 2000. As
you have seen, it's after the 1990 to 2000
period where I've shown the shade where
the warming rose above the background
noise. In fact thousands of scientists
said finally we are seeing the human
induced warming. So there, a forecast
turned out to be okay. So for the last
30-35 years, I've used a variety of
instruments. The one I've shown, the left
hand side is the satellite which I helped
to design that with three other scientists
at NASA. We were looking at the regulation
of the heat flow in and out of planet by
the atmosphere. More recently, we
developed this unmanned aircraft to look
at how the heating from man-made
pollutants is really warming the planet.
So let me walk you through. What we did
was, using this to track each of the
predictions by models and theories. And
see are they coming true. So the first
thing, we went after is what's called the
water vapour feedback. Remember, I think
Jeff showed several talks about the warmer
atmosphere holds more moisture. But water
vapour is the most powerful greenhouse
gas. So we determined the greenhouse
effect directly simply by estimating the
infra radiation coming from the ocean.
It's basically given by the Planck's
black-body law. When we were measuring the
heat escaping to the top of the
atmosphere, and differenced the two,
looked at the thickness of this blanket,
what you see here in the tropics is that
the blanket is thickest. Our unit for
measuring the thickness is watts of energy
trapped. So why is so much greenhouse
effect happening in the tropics? It's warm
and humid. Water vapor greenhouse effect.
But we're not satisfied with that. We
wanted to see as the planet warms would
the greenhouse water vapour increase. So
on the right hand side you see, we're not
gonna go through step by step, every year
the planners does a spectacular
experiment. It's the entire planet when
you average it's hottest during August and
coldest during February. Remember August
is winter in the Southern Hemisphere. So
when the temperature increases, we found
with the satellite the greenhouse effect
increased exactly as predicted by models.
And then you ask why did that increase?
That's the last bottom panel. It's because
the water vapor increased as the planet
temperature increased. So why is water
vapor increasing? It's basic
thermodynamics. The vapor pressure of
moisture above a body of water increases
exponentially with temperature. So here,
Arrhenius was the first to suggest it. The
next was another theory which was done by
Russian climatologist so-called C. I.
Sobriro. Charlie Kannel already
showed that. This took me 30 years to
start from the launch of the satellite to
come to this. I will say one of my
graduates student's thesis work: so as the
Arctic sea ice retreated, what the
climatologist said is, you know the ice
absorbs only 50% of the sunlight. It
bounces everything back. That's why it's
white. When you melt the ice away, you get
the sudden tipping point you will see the
dark ocean. And we documented that exactly
how much energy. And that energy increase,
although it's in a tiny part of the
planet, Arctic, was so large that it was
equal to one fourth of the greenhouse
effect of CO2 increase. Okay. Again this
was suggested but the magnitude or the
feedback is much larger than what the
models were using. The last one I want to
mention to you . . .one of the key things
we are after is: is a warmer planet going
to be more cloudy? Why is that an
important question? Clouds are one of the
most powerful regulators of sunlight. The
clouds are white because it's reflecting
50% to 70%. In our planet, both in the
Northern polar region, Southern polar
region, this massive extra tropical cloud
system. Remember that's what you see
when you fly across in the Pacific
Atlantic thick white, they are the
refrigerants for the planet. What we are
finding is, think of them as two white
umbrellas, they are shrinking, letting
in more sunlight in the tropical ocean.
Again an amplification. So when they put
all of these together- remember I
forecast in the 1980. Boldened by the
success of that, we made two forecasts
seven years ago. In fact, we have already
dumped enough gases to heat the planet by
two and a half degrees. We've only seen
about one third of it. The other thing,
which is what made me go after the pursuit
of the common good, is that we're gonna
hit this two degrees, not what people are
saying 100 years from now, around the
corner, 30 to 40 years from now. Okay. So
the so-called two degrees is facing us
already. So how do we slow down the
warming? Of course, you know most of the
studies talk about cutting down CO2 which
I agree with. So we came with a number to
reduce the long term warming. You've got
to stabilise the CO2 below 440 p.p.m. .
CO2 is already at 400, so to limit to 440,
we can't emit more than thousand billion
tons. That looks large but every year
we're emitting 40 billion tons. So we have
only 25 years left. Okay. But that's not
gonna help the near term warming because
CO2 is like a super tanker. Its lifetime
essentially is 1,000 years. [inaudible
00:13:05] So remember my work on the CFCs
that's put as HC, halocarbons, that's a
family of chemicals. And after that work
in '75, it came with numerous other
pollutants. Ozone, it's called smog.
Methane, we've heard about it. The other
is black carbon. It is soot the dark stuff
comes from diesel. It's not a greenhouse
gas, it's a particle that will absorb
sunlight. Much of my work with UAVs was to
track that. But we have technologies to
cut them down. And their lifetime is a few
weeks to a decade. If you eliminate black
carbon from diesel, their warming effect
is gone two weeks from now. So if we cut
these pollutants with existing
technologies, we can cut down the rate of
warming in the next 30 years by nearly
50%. So you need a two-pronged strategy.
So now let's look at who is gonna do
which. By the way, this idea of the CCAC,
the short-lived climate pollutants, I
wrote a paper of this for policy makers
with the political scientists at UCSD that
was read by Hillary Clinton. And she
formed a coalition three years ago, now
there are 40 nations that are working to
cut down the short-lived pollutants. So
now let's look at the human side of the
problem. For reasons I'm not gonna get
into, I spent, you know . . .took my
sabbatical and spent with my wife living
villages in India for three months. We
also do work in Kenya. And every week or
so the life in the village was so
oppressive I would escape to the nearest
city for a cold glass of beer. I have a
movie I will show you if there's time.
That's when I discovered, my god, there
are two worlds in this planet. The first
is inhabited by the top 1 billion with
obviously seemingly unlimited access to
fossil fuels. The other world is inhabited
by the bottom 3 billion, lack of access to
the fossil fuels even for cooking. They
still burn fire wood and cow dung. I was
having my meals in this woman's house
in the foothills of Himalayas. So the top
1 billion consumed 50% of the energy are
responsible for something like 50% to 70%
of the greenhouse gas emissions. So where
population is a problem as Doctor Hadley
said, the other big gorilla is
unsustainable consumption by a small part
of the world's population. Okay.
Particularly climate change. So in terms
of cutting CO2, the buzzword is
decarbonisation. So that takes about-,
to've been estimated about $1 trillion per
year. That's about $1,000 per person for
the top 1 billion. And there were fossil
fuel subsidies about $450 billion. So you
take it out, it's basically a $500 problem
we are arguing about. And then the second
thing is, the worst consequences of
climate change is going to be experienced
by the bottom 3 billion. This woman
represents about 600 million women around
the world who are on subsistence farming.
One or two to five acres. A draught like
what hit California extending for three,
four years would wipe them out. They will
become homeless, go to slums in cities,
etc. . So the question is we have to give
them energy access. And that has also been
costed out. It's about $250 billion. So if
you divide it amongst the top 1 billion,
it's a $250 problem. So the question you
have to ask is why should I living here,.
I am of course part of the top 1
billion. I'm almost on the top of the top
1 billion if you bring all my travels. So
why should I give $250 to this woman
sitting in Himalayas? If I don't do that,
she climbs on the fossil fuel ladder. Her
consumption of fossil fuel will go up by
30%. Now that will be 13 billion. So
purely selfish reasons, we want to provide
energy access. But if we now throw $250
billion, it's not gonna reach them. Right.
So we started a project called Surya where
we developed improved cook stoves to cut
down the emission. My
daughter developed cellphone technologies
to measure these emissions. My instruments
were all way too expensive. But this cook
stove is about $70 a person. That's about
five weeks of her pay check. Okay. So we
said she is cutting down climate by
cutting down the black carbon emissions
and CO2 emissions. She's saving about five
tons a year. So if I give the minimum
carbon credit to her which is about $15,
she'd get the stove paid off. And she'll
be making money next two, three years. But
how do you know she's gonna use it? That's
the biggest problem in compliance. So I
went to my daughter again. Asked her to do
something useful. She's a wireless
technology genius. So she came up with a
simple temperature sensor which heats as
soon as she starts the stove, the data
comes to her lab, she's at Los Angeles.
She shifts it to my lab. We convert the
carbon credits. UCSD created the first
climate mitigation fund. And we have
demonstrated it in 5,000 homes. In fact,
this work was started first by donation
from Qualcomm, Charlie Kannel and a
billionaire in San Francisco got it
started. So next week, this methodology
has been excepted by United Nations. I'll
be there in a summit. They're gonna
release it as one way to provide energy
access. So let me go on. So I'm now taken
my quantum mechanics to religious. So why
did I meet the Pope? Clearly we
particularly heard from the last speaker
and the previous speaker. I decided by the
way, I'm never going to follow Naomi
Oreskes. I was so mesmerised by what she
was saying, I forgot what I was gonna say.
So we teamed up. You know, I belong to the
Pope's academy of science with the
Economist, nobel laureates and biology,
physics, chemistry. In fact, Charlie and
Naomi attended that summit. And we
discussed this whole issue of
sustainability. And at the end of it we
were asked to brief to the Pope. And I've
been in this academy for the last . .
.every time we meet Pope like Pope John
Paul and Pope Benedict, it's always in the
most ornate room at the Vatican. This Pope
met us in the parking lot. Right here you
see. That's why he's called people's Pope.
So we briefed. What is remarkable about
this group, at the end of it, three days
of intense talks, we didn't talk about
technology, we didn't talk about this.
What we said was the main way to solve
this problem is to change our attitude
towards nature and towards each other. And
remember by leaving 3 billion behind,
they're gonna suffer the consequences of
our fuel consumption. And then from the
previous speaker we heard we're gonna be
generations of yet unborn suffering our
unsustainable consumption. So it's a moral
issue. So what we're saying is that
religious leaders should take hold of
this. And two weeks ago Pope Francis
because of this previous meeting,
assembled religious leaders from Islam,
Hindu, Jewish, all the religions
represented. And they all signed a
decoration. And anyway, so let me just
come to the last point. I joined this
infamous group, Planetary Boundaries
group. So we publish this Planetary
Boundary that is a safe eco-system. That's
the inner-circle. And then you exceed the
outer circle you go to the danger zone.
And so there were eight components we
identified. Was the only climate scientist
there. And climate change and then the
atmospheric aerosol loading is there. Two
of the components we already exceeded the
boundaries. Doctor Hadley's talk
beautifully showed that species
extinction. It turns out our extinction
rate is 10 to 100 times larger than when
we compared to extinction rates before
humans really started colonizing the
planet. The other major is nitrogen. You
know, fertilisers. We have anoxic zones in
the ocean. They're there because
pollutants, effluents from the ocean. So
climate change, there are denialists
because of political and economic reasons.
But our chairman also said we're also
denialists, it is coded into our genes. So
no matter how, if we don't do much about
it, I want to conclude with my prediction
that you'll see that the red zone, the
climate was still in the yellow zone, we
will exceed that by 2050, two degrees. So
the anthropocene which is coined by my
good friend, Paul Crutzen will reach
adolescence by 2050. I'm thinking they're
the teenagers the most dangerous age in
the human being's evolution. Right. So
we'll reach two degree world. But I
predict when it reach two degrees the
changes would be huge, just physically and
thermodynamically, the water vapor alone
would be 15% more. Fuelling the storms,
fuelling draughts, fuelling floods. So we
would change our attitude towards nature.
We will decarbonise the economy. But I'm
saying it's a $450 problem amongst the top
1 billion. It's safe to assume all of us
here belong to that prestigious club. And
then we need to provide clean energy for
the bottom 3 billion. Thank you very much.